en el siguiente diagrama cada lado de
los cuadrados pequeños tiene una
longitud de un centímetro y nos
preguntan cuál es el área de la figura y
bien aquí tenemos esta figura de azul y
queremos saber cuál es su área
recuerda el área es el espacio total que
cubre la figura y también se nos dice
que cada uno de estos cuadrados tienen
como lado un centímetro eso significa
que cada uno de estos cuadrados es de un
centímetro cuadrado
ahora bien podemos encontrar el área de
esta figura primero viendo cuántos
cuadrados cumple esta figura podríamos
decir que aquí tenemos un cuadrado de
estos uno de ellos por acá tengo uno más
este sería el segundo
y contar todos los cuadrados que tengo
adentro de esta figura pero también hay
otra opción la otra opción que podemos
hacer es observar la figura y
descomponerlo en dos figuras entonces
podemos decir que tenemos dos
rectángulos y los puedes ver aquí este
va a ser mi primer rectángulo quiero que
lo observen bien aquí tengo un
rectángulo y por otra parte aquí tengo
otro rectángulo este de aquí va a ser
otro rectángulo así que tenemos dos
rectángulos y podemos buscar el área de
cada uno de estos rectángulos y luego
sumar cada una de esas áreas para
encontrar el área total de la figura
bueno en el rectángulo de abajo tenemos
dos filas aquí las puedes ver una y dos
y cada una de ellas tiene
siete unidades cuadradas 17 centímetros
cuadrados así que si lo escribimos
tenemos dos filas dos filas que
multiplican a siete centímetros
cuadrados a siete centímetros cuadrados
lo que me da un total de catorce
centímetros cuadrados es decir el área
del rectángulo de abajo es de catorce
centímetros cuadrados o catorce
centímetros cuadrados cubren al
rectángulo de abajo ahora vamos a ver el
rectángulo de arriba y se observa
tenemos 12
45 filas y cada una de esas filas tienen
dos unidades cuadradas así que tenemos
cinco filas déjame notarlo cinco filas y
cada una de ellas tiene dos centímetros
cuadrados por dos centímetros cuadrados
eso me da un total de diez centímetros
cuadrados entonces al rectángulo de
arriba a este de verde lo cubren diez
centímetros cuadrados o tiene un área de
diez centímetros cuadrados y ahora si
sumamos estas dos áreas me va a quedar
que el área de este rectángulo verde es
diez centímetros cuadrados ya eso le voy
a sumar el área de este rectángulo de
color anaranjado que es 14 centímetros
cuadrados y así voy a obtener el área
total de la figura que buscábamos
así que 10 más
14 es lo mismo que 24 por lo tanto el
área final de mi figura que estaba
buscando inicialmente va a ser de 24
centímetros cuadrados de 24 centímetros
cuadrados porque el área recuerda que es
cuánto espacio cubre nuestra figura y
nos dimos cuenta que nuestra figura
cubre un espacio de 24 centímetros
cuadrados